would Resident Evil have ever seen the
light of day without this Bonkers
Japanese horror movie here's a look at
the Obscure Resident Evil precursor
you've never even heard of long before
the first Resident Evil game was
released in 1996 Sweets Home was laying
the groundwork for everything it would
become the movie and video game versions
of sweets home were both released in
1989 on the exact same day the two
versions were developed alongside each
other with some disagreement over which
ones started first that's any race the
film has a decidedly more video game you
feel than the vast majority of movies at
the time a Sweet Home video game was
released on the famicom console which is
essentially the Japanese equivalent of
the NES players take control of all five
of the film's main characters at
different points each with a unique
skill as it made their way through the
painter's mansion and try to escape the
gameplay consists primarily of
turn-based combat puzzle solving and
exploration the game features a much
wider range of enemy types that can be
seen in the film including everything
from suits of armor to skeletons
according to Bloody Disgusting the game
was never released outside of Japan
although the project was held back by
the technical limitations of the era it
was considered quite Innovative and
helped push the envelope forward in the
burgeoning horror game genre we don't
know what's going to happen the Sweet
Home film and video game can be counted
as a direct ancestor of the entire
Resident Evil franchise which is a clip
that's originates her in popularity and
reached several times over in truth
calling Sweets Home the inspiration for
Resident Evil might actually be an
understatement as explained by Goomba
Stone by the retrospective on Resident
Evil the project was first born as a
direct remake of the sweet home game
tokuru fujiwara created the original
game on The Limited Tech of 1989. but
after major advancements have been made
on video game Hardware in the early 90s
fujiwara wanted to create a 3D remake of
sweet home when Shinji makami was
assigned to lead the Remake he began
drifting further and further away from
the source material he will end up
pulling inspiration from the 1992 horror
game alone in the dark as well as the
zombie films of George A Romero making
the key enemies of the game zombies
Earth development continued it stopped
being considered a remake and took on
the new title of biohazard in some parts
of the world and Resident Evil in others
according to Kotaku even still traces of
the swede's home DNA can still be felt
the biggest cent piece sequences in
swedes home will lie heavily on complex
special effects these show stopper
moments include a mangled torso crawling
along the floor and leaving its legs
behind and a corpse in a wheelchair
erupting into molten gear there's also a
man's face melting off and a gigantic
ghostly lightning spewing monster of
Queen alien proportions the execution of
these key sequences represented make or
break moments for the film fortunately
the production was willing to seek out
the world's best special effects Talent
American special effects artist Dick
Smith had built up a sterling reputation
after working on world-class films like
The Godfather and their sequel Taxi
Driver the deer hunter Marathon Man and
Starman
Bingo he also most personally worked on
Gore showcases the exorcists and
scanners Smith was riding high of the
success of an Oscar win for Amadeus when
he was asked to fly to Japan to handle
the special effects for Sweet Home Smith
accepted the offer and delivered some
incredible results
in the 1980s CGI was still in its
infancy but things were beginning to
change by the end of the decade James
Cameron has long been at The Cutting
Edge of VFX and his film The Abyss
released the same year as sweet's home
pushed the form further than ever before
[Music]
computer-generated visuals are used
extremely sparingly and only really pop
up in a noticeable way in the ending
sequence of sweet home after being
reunited with a dead child and
transforming into an Angelic figure the
ghost Rises up into the sky seemingly
ascending to Heaven a simple 3D
environment rotates around the ghosts
that saw some underground past the
bonuses of the mansion and climbs all
the way up into the sky which then
crossfades back to a live-action
time-lapse shot of the sky
once settled so some viewers might miss
is related to the many murals within
Suite home as the Explorer deceased
painters abandoned mansion the
documentary crew and cover a number of
frescoes painted on the home's walls
these paintings are key to the goals of
the documentary crew but wind up being
largely inconsequential to the plot once
a supernatural occurrences begin taking
place the frescoes are a bigger part of
the Sweet Home video game as there are
far more of them and they provide
players with important Clues as unlikely
as it sounds the frescoes can also
provide viewers of the movie with Clues
as well but first Fresco uncovered by
the crew in particular is loaded with
foreshadowing the various images on the
mural including a single eye hair fire a
baby with a small coffin and a metal
door though seemingly innocuous upon
first glance each one points to a key
image that will pop up later in the film
for example the single eye for Shadows
of backstory of the ghost who lost an
eye trying to save her daughter and the
small coffin is dug up outside the
Mansion later on and contains the
ghost's dead daughter
the plus of this Japanese ghost story
Bears an awful lot in common with the
British one sweet's home and the woman
in black are both set primarily in
abandoned mansions haunted by the ghosts
of mothers whose children died in tragic
accidents both stories also climb up to
the protagonists digging up the corpse
of the ghost dead child outside and
returning yet to its rightful place
inside the Munchen the novel The Woman
in Black written by Susan Hill was first
published in 1983. in a striking
coincidence the first film adaptation of
the woman in black was made as a TV
movie and aired on British television
the same year sweet's home was released
it is possible that kiyoshi Kurosawa
poured some inspiration from the novel
when writing the sweets home screenplay
but the similarities may also be a
simple case of parallel thinking and
falling back on the touchstones of the
genre
hahaha
[Music]
the biggest Factor behind the obscurity
of sweets home today is a film having
never received an official release
outside of its Home Country it's enjoyed
a standard theatrical release in Japan
but wasn't distributed any further just
like as video game counter bar when it
came for home media products sweet home
was released on VHS and LaserDisc but
again only in Japan all these years
later the film has still never made its
way abroad in any official capacity it
has never been released on DVD or
Blu-ray or even made available as a
stream on any service though a VHS rip
has appeared on YouTube anyone outside
of Japan looking to view the film
through traditional means will likely
have to resort to importing an old
physical copy of it rare VHS copies of
the film typically go from between 100
and 200 on eBay LaserDisc copies of the
film are even rarer but do exist since
these dated formats are the only ways to
watch the film in the Modern Age the
resolution is quite poor fans of the
movie would entously be happier if it
cleaned up remastered edition of the
film or release on Blu-ray but the
rights are owned by Touhou pictures
Incorporated who have shown no interest
in a re-release one of the most
important characters in sweet's home is
Emmy the teenage daughter of the
documentary director after the ghost
begins picking off the crew one by one
the priority becomes getting Emmy out of
the house alive at a certain point she
appears to be dead but Akiko sets us out
that this is a test and bravely
hallucinated flames on the fury of the
ghost to save her the role of Emmy was
played by nabuko Yamada he was better
known by her stage name Narco at the
time the film was released Narco was at
the height of her famous lead singer of
the pop rock band Rebecca the band broke
up a couple of years after the release
of sweet home but Narco went on to have
a successful solo career she gives a
solid performance but sweet home is the
only film in which Narco ever appears
sweet home was directed by kiyoshi
Kurosawa in the early stage of his
career Kurosawa would go on to find
major International critical success
later on in his career Bert was still
finding his footing in the 1980s in the
beginning of his career Kurosawa worked
his way up as a director of pink films
these were a type of popular Japanese
movie that included elements of softcore
pornography these days he works at a
dramatically different level and as a
returning favor to the prestigious
Cannes Film Festival after having been
winning several Awards over the years
his later work is a world apart from
sweet's home he continued working
frequently in the horror genre however
his filmmaking style will become defined
by subtlety restraint and
thought-provoking themes none of which
can be found in the over-the-top
bombastic sweet home it should come as
no surprise then that Kurosawa disown
this early effort though Kurosawa wrote
and directed the film ownership of
Sweets Home in its final form is often
attributed to producer juzo Itami
Kurosawa and atami Clash behind the
scenes and Kurosawa was left unsatisfied
by the end result
kiyoshi kurasawa and Jose Itami work
together a handful of times over the
years itamiyak didn't Bumpkin soup which
Kurosawa wrote and directed and Kurosawa
acted in the funeral which atami wrote
and directed after trading off
responsibilities and a couple of
projects they joined powers for sweet
home but they ended up butting heads
behind the scenes and fighting for
Creative control its Army started out
his career as an actor in the 1960s but
pivoted to focus on writing directing
and producing in the 80s he found
success as a director with acclaimed
films like the funeral and tampopo and
didn't look back
foreign
says he was one of the few filmmakers
who have consistent commercial success
in Japan throughout the 80s he decided
that his final acting role would be in
sweet's home with his past collaborator
kiyoshi Kurosawa he plays a now cliche
role of the old man who works at the gas
station and wants a documentary crew not
to go in the haunted house later on
going in to save them
the butting of heads between writer
slash director kiyoshi Kurosawa and
actor producer juzo Itami behind the
scenes led to many changes in the end
product by all the county Tami wrestled
creative control away from Kurosawa by
the time the film was locked as covered
by Bloody Disgusting Itami disagreed
with many of kurosawa's creative
decisions and took matters into his own
hands after Kurosawa had finished the
film Itami went back and heavily altered
it his changes included extensive
re-editing but he also went so far as to
reshoot scenes without kurosawa's input
and others at weren't in kurosara's
script but midnight I Itami was one of
the most bankable filmmakers of 80s
Japan the majority of his alterations
fell in line with making sweet homea
more crowd-pleasing and commercially
viable movie but came at the expense of
kurosawa's more artistic sensibilities
these changes are a major part of why
kuasawa disown the film his original cut
of the movie was never released on home
video so its Army's version is the only
one available to watch today there is
really no telling how drastically
different kurosawa's version might be
there is however a slim chance that his
director's Kirk could still see the
light of day at some point according to
midnight Tai a copy of the director's
cut lives with a film print in SOHO
Studio vaults will we ever see it it's
doubtful but the next time he boost up a
Resident Evil game remember that it may
have never happened without the weird
obscure wonder that is sweet home
[Music]